hello Internet welcome to film Theory
where no matter how much the theorist
Dynasty grows we promise to never get a
big head but theorists my buddy Paul
Rudd is back I'm Paul Rudd star of such
hit as I love you man with a new hit
movie Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
maybe hit is overselling it a bit based
on audience review scores for this one
so uh let me just try that again of all
the MCU movies Ant-Man quantumania is
one of them says a lot about a movie
when the most excitement I get is the
final title that reveals that the words
Ant-Man were actually hidden in Quantum
Mania the entire time I was like whoa no
way it's like when you find out that the
FedEx logo has a secret Arrow hiding
inside of it but with this latest
release we officially have entered the
beginning of MCU Phase 5 where as the
marketing hype says nothing will ever be
the same which is actually very much the
same for Marvel movies hey guys maybe
maybe just consider changing up your
press releases every once in a while or
you know what never mind scratch that
maybe I should be careful what I wish
for considering change is the thing that
single-handedly drove this movie Into
The Ground well that and Soggy Bottom
Modoc seriously this is like the
alternate universe if they had waited to
reveal ugly Sonic is part of the movie
here we're just stuck with this thing
for two hours anyway if you're really
into PG Rick and Morty episodes then
this one is the movie for you
ihole man whether you like the film or
not something that I've seen everyone
agree on is that things felt off about
the story scenes that felt awkwardly
placed moments that resolved too quickly
character arcs that were more like
character Cliffs and this time there's
no one around to break the fourth wall
and argue with producers about it none
of these storylines make any sense is
this working for you something major
changed here and I'm not just talking
about normal production stuff where
things get left on The Cutting Room
floor there's another movie hiding in
here somewhere one that got chopped up
shuffled around re-edited rearranged and
reshot for some reason and I want to
know what that original movie was I want
to see the story that this was trying to
tell because my boy Ant-Man deserved
better I wanna still care about this
franchise and it's Pharaoh Kang that
looks like it just rolled out of the
Party City I want to but it's getting
real hard and if I need to stop caring
about this franchise I want to know what
went wrong along the way short version
get it short anyway I think at one point
Scott Lang's adventure to the quantum
realm not only had a very different much
darker ending it also had a more
complicated morally complex story arc
for the main character but here's the
biggest twist I think solving what this
movie could have been tells us a
fascinating tale of the major mistakes
that Marvel and the rest of Hollywood
are making right now okay so let me give
you the quick recap of the movie we got
so we can then you know actually piece
together the movie we should have got so
it's 2025 and Scott Lang is kinda sort
of retired from Ant Manning since there
really hasn't been an Avengers level
threat lately except for a city being
taken hostage a giant Kaiju Battle over
Egypt the Multiverse ripping apart in
the complete Rampage of a deadly witch
gone Rogue everyone just forgot Scott's
number for those since then he wrote a
book available on audible.com I have no
doubts meanwhile hope is running Pim
Industries as a do-good or girl boss
Hank is collecting fat paychecks for
mildly reacting to CGI and Janet is
definitely not talking about what she
did while stuck in the quantum realm for
the past 30 years seriously don't even
bring it up she just doesn't have time
to talk about it right now okay guys as
for Scott's daughter Cassie she's all
grown up into a completely different
human being she's also grown up to be an
active this stealing cop cars and
protesting for the land rights of blip
victims so basically she's a flag
Smasher but don't worry it's okay for
her to do it because she's the hero's
daughter she also thinks that the
grown-ups in her life are kinda resting
on there save the world at one time
Laurels instead of being as angry about
all this stuff like she is then Everyone
Gets Zapped into the quantum realm so
this whole Boomers versus zoomer's
allegory can play out with cool monsters
and lasers how you communicated by
metaphor the good guys get split up
between Hank hope and Janet so she can
very slowly reveal the plot while Scott
and Cassie get caught up with a group of
refugees being oppressed by an evil
dictator Kang the Conqueror yeah it's
going exactly where you think it is this
is the kind of cause that Cassie is
super passionate about and she wants to
use her powers to Hell Scott meanwhile
says it's not their fight he's only
focused on getting her home and with
that we've set up yet again the clear
ideological divide between these two
characters that will then see inevitably
play out over the next two hours oh wait
Scott just decides to agree with Cassie
uh okay that was quick to resolve itself
well anyway Cassie gets captured by Kang
forcing Ant-Man to cooperate this game
ultimately return storm in the castle
with their ragtag army of refugees Kang
blasts a lot of people with a
disintegration laser but then makes the
Strategic decision to only punch all the
named characters eventually the script
writers remember it's an Ant-Man movie
so Kang is ultimately overwhelmed by an
army of CGI ants oh and Modoc is here
and then right before they escape the
quantum realm through a portal Kang
returns Scott makes the ultimate
self-sacrifice by pushing the rest of
his family to safety while he gets the
beat down of his life
just as it looks like he's about to die
hope comes in through the closing portal
to finish off Kang for good maybe he's
gotten hoped get a big dramatic Heroes
looking out over Victory wide shot
perfect for an ambiguous but hopeful cut
to Black Cliffhanger and thus the movie
ends with Scott and hope trapped in the
quantum realm with Cassie and the rest
of the Young Avengers having to work to
get him back wait another record scratch
that is like two times we've used the
same bit this episode no uh actually
instead of being stranded in the quantum
realm Cassie immediately opens another
portal to the real world somehow and we
get a weirdly abrupt happy ending Coda
almost entirely in vo where Scott
wonders whether Kang will return and
then two post-credit scenes in the end
of the film teaser confirmed that yes
yes he will return so uh that's the
movie and largely it works as a film I
guess are there plot threads left
awkwardly dangling absolutely is it an
Ant-Man movie no definitely not but all
of those things weren't what set my
theorist senses a tingling what really
convinced me to start digging deeper
here was the ending everything that
happens from when Cassie turns the
portal back on looks a lot like
something that was put together after
the fact in post-production using a
bunch of recycled b-roll a few minimal
reshoots and new voice over I mean
Scott's self-sacrifice fake out lasts
less than a minute just from a visual
storytelling perspective alone doesn't
fit the very affectionate hug it out
family above all tone that the rest of
the movie sets up no big how am I gonna
get out this time moment no big reunion
scene on the other side of the portal no
restatement of the lessons that were
learned along the way this is Marvel
Studios here people if that stuff ain't
in there it's because it wasn't shot to
begin with Kevin runs himself a tight
ship the most advanced entertainment
algorithm in the world and it produces
near perfect Prada and that conclusion
is supported by leaks that happened as
far back as last September which said
that while no one was meant to die in
the end hope and Scott Were Meant to get
stranded in the quantum realm that shot
of Cassie turned on the portal I
suspected it was originally going to be
her activating something else entirely
possibly even as part of a post-credits
scene my personal head Canon is that she
was flipping a switch to Signal her
father's old team to come help him her
first confirmation that the Avengers are
coming back except this time they're
young you won't even even need to know
who the Avengers actually were at this
point just a tense zoom on a digital
screen and then but also a
self-sacrificial ending here makes
logical sense as well see well it might
be a bit of an exaggeration to say apple
movies all in the same way wait who's
saying that one thing you probably did
notice is that heroic self-sacrifice
happens a lot Far and Away the mcu's
third favorite Trope after bad dads and
villains who are actually evil versions
of the hero Thor giving up Jane to stop
Loki Wanda lose Envision to destroy the
Mind Stone black widow eating herself
off the cliff for the Soul Stone when Wu
protecting his son from the dweller in
darkness Peter Parker given up his life
to fix the Multiverse and of course Iron
Man's sacrificed to snap away Thanos
heck the way that we know that Captain
America is the goodest of the good guys
is that he's a jump on the grenade guy
at the beginning of his story without
needing to learn any lessons about
humility or respect on the way be ready
to lay down your life for others is the
moral Baseline of the MCU it's the thing
that makes the good guys the good guys
here even newer characters are being put
to the same tried and true test in
Multiverse Madness America Chavez is
only able to defeat evil Wanda after she
says that she'd be willing to sacrifice
herself for the good of the many then
and only then is she able to become a
Marvel hero who can sucker punch someone
who once held her own against Thanos
what all of these stories have in common
is that the sacrifice is the payoff to
an arc in the growth of the character
Thor learns how to put others needs
ahead of his own America stops running
from her problems Tony's been trying to
make up for being an arms dealer since
he became Iron Man and here's the thing
Ant-Man movies have already used the
Trope in the first film Scott shrinks to
Quantum size to protect Cassie 1.0 and
therefore stop the man who would be
Modoc even though as far as he knew
there was no coming back from that
choice why then would they do the same
kind of payoff here again in the third
outing well here's one possibility what
if that subplot about Scott and Cassie
butting heads over when and how to get
involved in other people's fights that
just kind of resolves itself in one
scene was originally meant to be a much
bigger deal as in the entire point of
the movie kinda bigger one thing I made
fun of in my plot summary about the
movie but that's really frustrating when
you actually watch it is how slowly
Janet reveals information about Kang she
knows that he's been down here the
entire time in fact she's the one who
helped Kang rise to power she's the
reason all of this is happening and why
all these Rick and Morty rejects are
being oppressed but the movie delivers
that information to us in a weird way
they drip feed it to us at a snail's
pace like much longer than a typical
movie would deliver this information
they keep the name of the villain's
secret for a bunch of the run time of
the film referring to Kang as him all of
them talking in hushed tones much longer
than you would expect and the fact that
Janet is split up from Scott and Cassie
means that even when she does finally
find the time to explain her backstory
like an hour into the film Scott and
Cassie still wouldn't know the danger
that's around him I suspect that the
film was originally structured this way
so that Kang's appearance and the fact
that he's evil would be a big middle of
the movie Reveal now that might seem
like a big leap but consider what this
does to the character arcs in the film
what if in an earlier version of the
movie Scott didn't take Cassie's side
right away instead he kept trying to
only protect her as a result he takes up
Kang's go get a thing for me offer
willingly despite her objections because
from his perspective hey we don't know
what's happening down here really he
seems to be the guy in charge why are we
assuming the weird aliens who made us
drink goo are the good guys that then
reinforces the opening beats of the
movie The generational Gap and their
different priorities then it all goes
wrong and the rest of the story plays
out mostly the same hey I'm Kang thanks
for helping me achieve my true power now
if you'll excuse me I'm just gonna go
oppress everything look at what that
does Scott suddenly realizes that he was
wrong all along he feels guilty for
enabling this villain and needs to do an
MCU heroic sacrifice trademarked to
atone for it thereby reaffirming his
Good Guy status while also establishing
Cassius having had the clear more
righteous moral judgment all along
there's even this really strange moment
in the actual film that makes me feel
like we're really onto something here
just before the big final battle Scott
stands up in giant man mode to confront
Kang and he has this angry line shouting
more seriously than we've ever heard
this character sound we had a deal our
word is our bond which okay he's mad he
should be but why is he outraged that
Kang a guy he just found out existed a
guy that he only knows as an evil
dictator it's got really that surprise
that he was dishonest with him he has no
reason to have assumed that he could
trust Kang unless all of that is a
Remnant from a version of the story
where he did gotta tell you theorists
all the pieces are in place for us it
fixes the broken story arcs it explains
the awkwardly paced storytelling it
corrects the uncomfortable and re-shot
ending Kang's heel turn was meant to be
a Twist reveal rather than a core part
of all the marketing so why then did
they make such a drastic change and in
the process butcher this movie To Pieces
because I suspect that this wasn't meant
to be a phase 5 movie This was meant to
be the end of phase four let me explain
if I'm right about what this movie's
plot and ending Were Meant To Be look at
what we're left with a dark story about
oppression not trusting Authority and an
ideological divide between older and
younger generations of Heroes that
doesn't sound like an Ant-Man movie but
it does sound like a Marvel phase 4
project for all its disjointed weirdness
phase four did have itself a consistent
theme instability characters grappling
with the realization that defeating
Thanos literally thwarting the end of
the universe didn't end every other
problem forever they're still suffering
Injustice inequality some of it got even
worse and now there are big disagree
comments over what to do about that
especially between people who feel like
the biggest fight ever has already been
won and those who think the fight has
only just started which of course Falls
across generational lines and it's here
that we pit a rising crop of young
Heroes who want to fight the power and
often hail from backgrounds that are uh
well less significantly heavy on white
guys named Chris against older Heroes
who just want to retire Hawkeye and
Ant-Man just want to be dads the Hulk is
into meditation now the entire nation of
wakanda just wants to be left alone
again and if you're really into
heavy-handed metaphors in Multiverse
Madness Scarlet Witch goes full super
villain by trying to rip the life force
out of a Latina teenager in order to
resurrect a fake version of the American
dream that only ever existed in Her
Imagination even the blackest sheep of
phase 4 Thor 11 Thunder got in on these
same themes of instability and
generational change I mean the bad guy
wants to literally kill every God you
don't get much more anti-authority than
that and the movie ultimately agrees
with Gore we see that the gods do suck
Thor is only able to win by blowing up
his franchise's Chosen One conceit by
declaring that all the kids are worthy
to be Thor and that anything from random
junk to a teddy bear can be as good as
mjolnir that right there that is Phase
Four's narrative in one place the system
is falling apart to people in charge are
either corrupt or failing to fix it the
young people know what's what and
they're the ones who are Gonna Save Us
the righteous path for any OG Avenger
still kicking around is to Aid mentor
and pass that torch to the Next
Generation Ant-Man getting tricked into
empowering a time-hopping multiversal
dictator him and the wasp getting
trapped and needing help from a younger
generation of Heroes sounds like a solid
way to bring all these themes together
and end this Arc of Storytelling on a
cliffhanger that then gets us eager for
the next major chapter of the story in
the new phase five so then why would
they have changed quantumania's story
they called it the blip in this case I'm
talking about the real world blip 2020
covet happened not only delaying movie
release dates but the entire real world
global economy movie production was at a
standstill theaters were closing people
were turning to YouTube and Tick Tock
for their entertainment suddenly the
pressure was on for Marvel to
single-handedly save the cinema thing
things had to be churned out as fast as
possible whenever they were able to get
finished looking at Marvel's original
release schedule for phase four you see
that the plan was to gradually introduce
the Multiverse as opposed to throwing it
all out there at once no longer was
there a chance to slowly build up to the
reveal of Kang he had to be put out
there front and center people loved
Thanos after all they'll have to love
this guy too make end game happen again
because the world almost ended and the
movie Biz is on the verge of dying
pandered how Corporate suits Siege and Z
make sure that fans are satisfied by
giving a Modoc they've been asking for
him for a while bigger scale older
choice is multi-screen viewing
experiences look at this graph of MCU
content released by year 2021 had five
times the amount of content of any other
year before it it was a rush a move of
desperation to recover after a year
without theaters except in all of this
rush they forgot why people came out to
these movies in the first place the
stories the characters not Gears of a
plot working together or fan service for
the sake of fan service earned moments
with tight narratives compelling stories
that made sense without massive plot
holes not an over-reliance on quippy
dialogue but dialogue that was funny
because yeah that would be what that
character would say in that moment
what's killing the MCU right now and
especially Quantum antia here are moves
that are made out of panic self-doubt a
lack of confidence in the stories that
they plan to tell re-edits that result
in choppy uneven compromised narratives
as films are hacked to Pieces it took
the Marvel Brand which used to act as a
seal of quality that's now reduced it
into something that yeah maybe maybe
I'll go see that when it airs on
streaming the last time a studio acted
in this sort of panicked way rushing to
get to the next big event I was DC we're
still watching how long it's taken them
to turn things around and there you have
it theorists the darker story for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania are we
rights totally off will we ever know
it's hard to say what I'm sure about is
that this isn't going to be the last
time that this genre of Theory comes up
the whole media industry is still
putting itself back together after years
of huge world-shaping events and even if
it didn't play out as dark as it might
have the most relatable story that this
movie tried to tell is that you can't
really unchange the world only decide
how you are gonna respond to it but hey
that's just a Theory a film Theory and
cut
[Music]
foreign